[Music]
i actually know i went to silver lake
this weekend and i had a bagel at some
place
and there was awesome
[Laughter]
there's this girl she was outside
of the place and she was talking and she
had this voice that i could only
describe
it's like a certain type of
voice that some people have where it's
like they're permanently exhaling out of
a hookah okay
like it's like
yeah it's just like this is like
something like knotted yeah it's yeah
yeah and then oh that's pretty good
yeah there i was over there
oh sounds good
oh man i don't know yeah like their
tonsils are swollen yeah something yeah
um anyway awesome mcbroom's tonsils are
about to be swollen from the sheer
throat [ __ ] all these lawyers are
gonna do to him
yeah so this video actually
go watch this video yeah because it's
really good what's this guy's name again
can we scroll down
already
oh noel your backup channel where you do
lawyer commentary
yeah that bald guy is you shut it down
don't even do it shut it down before you
even go and just stop you know back it
up back it up
back it up and remember that you're a
grown ass woman with bangs and you need
to cut them
it's over
okay you're 27 get rid of the bangs
you work now
it's over
okay we got your goth girl days are over
it's it's sorry anyway
um yeah spencer what is it cornelius
spencer cornelia
cornelia i can't see that yeah uh he's a
lawyer right
i actually don't know
what if he's just a guy
saying [ __ ] that's not real what do you
mean just like making up law [ __ ] just
like
i mean
he didn't really say that much like
lawyer [ __ ] in this video he may not
just like reading the
uh contract or no the the lawsuit and
then
you know like putting it into layman's
terms sorry okay you off that header
send it to our voicemail scroll up i
make dope videos
i love the confidence he is really funny
he's a licensed real estate agent
okay
okay well [ __ ] it
my man wants to cover legal drama on the
side yeah do you brother [ __ ] that'd be
so crazy he does a house showing and
someone's like
what spencer
dude you're my favorite lawyer
dude you're my fav
you do real estate
oh yeah
i'm not a lawyer
this whole time bro
i thought
anyways there's this recap video
digging into the
case details of the whole awesome
mcbroom uh live x live social glove [ __ ]
and the gist of it is it seems like
austin mcgroom
is [ __ ] yeah
finance like truly
he's in way over his head now yeah
because the live x live i didn't know
that they're a public company
yeah publicly traded company which means
they got lawyers
yeah and team so they know how to put on
live events that's what they do
and so i think austin came to
them
and basically they partnered
um over the streaming of this event
basically i think that's how it started
right it was just the broadcasting yeah
sure yes and then
and and maybe the pay-per-view system
uh-huh something like that yep and then
they were like well we don't have a
venue so can you get a venue for us and
live live was like okay we can get a
venue he basically like negotiated a lot
more stuff into the deal
and
including like booking the music artists
um and what austin was doing was
he was in charge of like booking the
other fighters and then giving them
contracts
and so he went out there thinking that
he was going to sell
two million pay-per-view buys which
would be the fifth biggest pay-per-view
event ever yeah
right after the canelo verse whoever
mayweather fight and then above
nate connor two
yeah nate connor two that's not even one
yeah that's the middle of the rivalry
yeah
so he he really thought that they were
gonna get two million pay-per-view buys
at fifty dollars a pop
which would have generated a hundred
million 100 million dollars yeah but
that was his number when he went out to
the fighters and was like hey bryce hall
i'll give you five million bucks yep
that's because he thought he was gonna
like for some reason he thought they
were gonna convert two million people to
buy this
50
event so insane
and now they're suing him
yeah damages because live x live put so
much money into the event and they're
not going to get paid back for it and
now taylor holder is suing them rice
hall suing him because the and the
interesting part is with the taylor
holder and the bryce hall deals he cut
those on the side
what a dummy bro what do you mean he
didn't like he didn't tell live x live
like about that
wow
so those agreements were between
austin's company and
and taylor's like
you know bryce bryce hall productions
llc and you know austin mcbroom whatever
the [ __ ]
um
so they're
you know they're suing his llc which i
imagine he's gonna try to like just file
bankruptcy and just tell him
s my d yeah but
maybe a judge wouldn't go for that and
the judge would be like well clearly you
have a history of like scamming people
so you need to pay them what they're
owed yeah
um
you know what would be really funny is
if taylor holder has to go in there
and really play up that he lost the
fight
yeah and he has to go in there and be
like i was beat up for 25 minutes
by gibb and then gibbs in the [ __ ]
courtroom like who hit you
yeah
that's right
admit it you lost
yeah and it's like really played up to
like
you know
i was fearing for my conjure up some
compassion from the jury yeah yeah just
look at this video look at how i got my
hat i got my ass slapped
i got spit i got spanked
and look at this i'm fighting like a
little boy
isn't that sad look at how hard i'm
getting spanked
[Laughter]
turn them on
look at me getting slapped around in
there
look at me all greased up look at how
hard i'm sweating wow it's working so
hard look at me i'm getting slapped look
at the filthy little deviant i am
getting just absolutely manhandled
by a smaller man looks at like jury
juror number seven think about that
think about it you're like five seven
think about manhandling me let me ask
the jury a question
would you like to manhandle me
how would that feel for you think about
it
think about my sweaty body pressed up
against yours
and you're slapping me in the in the ass
i think about me taking that
for five whole rounds yeah
ten minutes of uninhibited manhandling
and ass slapping
really picture it
oh yeah
[Applause]
picture me getting owned
i'm getting owned
then bright oh bro that's going to be
the best price hall gets in there
i'm not a fighter
[Laughter]
it's all going to come back full circle
the judge was like nah man you said
you're right 40 street never claimed to
be a fighter actually we have you on
record right here brother
that would be hysterical yeah
um
so yeah and then austin mcbroom you know
live ex live they're suing him for a
hundred mil i don't think they'll get a
hundred mil
i i feel like they'll get something
is that what they spent on that [ __ ] i
mean they rented out hard rock stadium
that in itself has to be a million yeah
no i think they're suing him for 100
million dollars jesus go back to that go
back to that article i thought that was
in the headline
uh
maybe i'm yeah 100 million yeah
yeah so it's this is scary because who
runs the company is austin and his
father
and like meanwhile there's a picture of
uh not only austin but his family on a
gigantic private jet on the way to the
fight it's like
so like there's no way to like justify
expenses for him like he can't really
say oh like i did this out of good faith
because i wanted the event to be great
it's like well you're blowing
however many thousands of dollars on
just completely unnecessary things like
private jets for example yeah and i'm
looking down because i'm looking up like
who's on the
board of directors
um
of of live super good productions or
what's his what's his production company
called oh yeah it was it was like the
gods only or like
what is it it was something really pg
isn't it corny
sound it's like super good production
simply greatness production simply
simply i like super good better
got super good super good productions
i mean that's what we make dude
they're just super everything
[ __ ] sick productions
i'm just trying to think of uh
oh damn live x live appoints nike vice
president chris wright i mean who knows
if he's actually good at his job
yeah so one of the comments was like
which i actually
kind of resonated with was
he was like live x live gets no sympathy
from me
like if you're partnering with austin
mcbroom oh do five minutes of research
to see
how much money that guy spends and how
much he cons his fans yeah then it's
your own fault too 100
but i mean like for
you know it's like probably a room full
of suits that are just like wait this
guy's going to get how many of the
biggest influencers in one room to fight
that's definitely going to sell
so i mean i don't know because it was 50
million confined like
followers across everyone
you know who was mentioned yeah but even
that it's like
i mean here's the thing
that number
you know
on paper like that sounds like a good
number but there's like a billion people
in the united states and
out of all those people
only one
only two million bought a pay-per-view
to watch conor mcgregor at arguably like
close to the peak of his career yeah
nate diaz who has like a decade's worth
of mma
like brand name like he's like the
[ __ ] one of the villains of the ufc
it took that to sell two million yeah so
i don't even know how it's an enter like
a media company you look at those 50
million followers and even [ __ ]
flinch at that or get excited because
who gives a [ __ ] yeah like that is
literally a penny in the ocean relative
to how many people you can sell
pay-per-views to yeah
sorry i was going to say this i really
actually do feel for bryson taylor in
this no i do 100 they
were like they thought that they were
going to get millions of dollars
for training for this thing stepping in
the ring yep they're probably planning
purchases they're gonna make afterwards
i know taylor bought a [ __ ] like
range rover or not range rover a [ __ ]
rolls royce or something yeah
um
you know and i'm not saying like i'm not
saying i feel bad for him that he bought
that before he got made sure to get paid
or whatever i'm just saying these kids
were promising promised millions of
dollars they signed a [ __ ] contract
yeah we will pay you five million
dollars as soon as you step in the ring
and now they're spending money on
lawyers and
in hopes of getting this money back that
they're never going to get back yep
because they're going to file for
bankruptcy and they'll never just [ __ ]
them over
and i i i give
i give them a pass and that they're
young bro like
it it's easy to be young and make a
stupid mistake like that like not
everyone is privy to entertainment it's
easy like sit back and go oh you should
this and you should that but bro if
you're like
21 and you sign some contract and
there's all these people around you it's
very reasonable that you would go yeah
this is legit yeah i'm definitely gonna
get that money yeah
and they got the roughest lesson in all
of it that's why i like
um
uh
someone hit us up to
you know someone i know hit us up to
like potentially like roast bryce hall
and i and i was just like honestly i
don't
like we'll joke about him but i don't
think it's shitty what he went through
now yeah like he essentially he got
conned out of the money
and he was a laughingstock he oh he just
destroyed his image yeah you know and
it's just like it may you could argue
all right that all could have been worth
it
for the money right like he quote
however you want to say it he sold out
and he would have got paid
but now that dude just took a a beating
from the guy who set it all up yeah who
debatably knew i'm never gonna pay this
full [ __ ] yeah so you sign a contract
here ass whooped
no payment and that's it yeah
and who knows what the [ __ ] kind of
injuries he took from that and what was
the side bet that they made was it one
million dollars yeah it was like one
mill about like winning or losing it's
wild
it's so crazy he has three kids
three kids and you're betting a million
dollars what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
save that for their college yeah
i mean you know
austin's used to
conning people so i'm sure
he was very confident betting that mill
like i'm never going to pay him even if
i [ __ ] lose so what happens in this
situation like he has his personal
wealth he has this
entity
that is partnered with live x live that
is now getting sued for 100 million
bucks so they report bankruptcy and
their debts are waived i think what
would happen is austin isn't affected at
all i think
they would probably fold the company
right
forego any of the because all the money
was put into an escrow yeah so i think
they would forego any of those earnings
so like that's the money they would for
sure collect on
and then
the only other option
would be
for live x live probably to go after him
personally like you know sue him
personally
and that i would imagine that would be a
tougher case because then they have to
like
you know the burden of proof is probably
really extensive yeah that's that's i
think idubbbz kind of touched on that
in the way of like getting people in
trouble for
pump and dump scams because
the
the what you need to successfully
execute on a case like that is so
[ __ ] difficult yeah so that's why
those people never get
put in jail yeah
so that's why through all this he
probably doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like
yeah i'm just gonna file bankruptcy on
all three entities and like i'm good
yeah but doesn't that like ruin his
credit or no
um
like you mean like his credit as a
person yeah oh yeah definitely but
because like that's worrisome then he'll
never get another mortgage
you know like yeah well it doesn't
matter because he doesn't pay those
anyway but yeah i guess
i don't know how this [ __ ] works i just
know like i don't know if you're if you
start a company and now you're getting
sued
for 100 million bucks that has to like
destroy you somehow
yeah i i what i think is the judge
i don't know it all depends on the on
the judge
the judge may go
hey austin you you know
you didn't make these efforts you didn't
fulfill these you know parts of the
because that that was the greatest quote
in that whole video is
uh when they asked austin to promote the
fight he said
quote like
we have six million subscribers we don't
need to do anything
oh man
eating those words
we don't have to do any marketing eating
those words right now yeah
yeah yeah they said he was like being
like comically irresponsible with the
promotion that he agreed to yeah like
just not doing it
in terms of like you know
stories and stuff that he agreed to post
like a number of them and he just wasn't
doing them why wouldn't you want to do
that
because you think it's like below you
that's what i'm saying the dude thinks
he's drake yeah
yeah man you know and i just have to say
i'm not sitting here like
you know i'm i'm not sitting here like
walking back any of the [ __ ] jokes
i've made on like bryce or taylor but
i do think
it is objectively really shitty
to like
uh
get injuries from a combat event and not
have any coverage because
austin was teeing off on them yeah he
does not know what that's going to do to
him later yeah he really doesn't yeah
so
yeah i think that's the shitty part
that's really rough yeah
it's crazy that that he got beat up by
the dude that's what i'm saying i know
that's what you said but like no no it
really is pretty wild when you say it
back to yourself like four or five times
like wait that dude welcomed his ass and
was not gonna pay him that's so crazy
yeah that's [ __ ] up that's like evil
yeah
it's [ __ ] nuts i guess austin was
supposed to get paid 5 million too
so like he clearly really thought that
they were going to sell that many
pay-per-views yeah definitely
on the event titled youtuber vs tick
talker
2 million pay-per-view buys
you know dana posted by social gloves
like at least come up with better names
you know dana white is laughing his ass
off when he sees this [ __ ]